so many of us are using camera phones
and sometimes tablets to make some
pretty terrific pictures I made this one
I was sauteing some colorful peppers and
when I put the cover on I saw what I
thought would be a pretty beautiful
image so of course I quickly grabbed my
phone and that's what this is about
isn't it the ability to quickly take a
picture without a big deal using phone
cameras to quickly make images when we
see something interesting or in this
case something very beautiful in my
opinion so did my son by the way who
made a whole series of photographs of my
amazing birthday party with my family at
per se in New York the dishes were
created by chef Jared hugh 'the and so
these pictures are basically portraits
of each course all taken with his camera
phone and by the way i adjusted the
color later on before uploading all of
these for this tutorial and here when we
were permitted to take a look at the
kitchen we see a place very much like a
laboratory showing process and equipment
and people doing their thing so camera
phones do have an important place for a
means of making very quick portraits of
various places in the lab of the work of
the equipment you can think about taking
the picture and then cropping it for
example as I did here but for the most
part the quality of the photograph is
not what we're encouraging in this
course if you remember we did a
comparison between two images of a petri
dish one with my phone camera and one
with the flatbed scanner at a higher
resolution well here is another
difference for example of the device
that we've seen before with a phone
camera and with my digital camera and
you'll see that the information is just
not there in the phone camera because of
the file size is just too small but once
again I'm going to say there is
definitely a place for these very quick
and impulsive images which you're seeing
now for the use of web designs for
example I was having a really great time
walking around this lab making a few
images which worked better with a little
bit of cropping and in fact were used
for the labs website so there is a place
for this kind of photography but
remember the quality is just not there
and is not good enough for a journal
article and certainly not a cover it
might well be someday the technology is
constantly changing with each iteration
of the phone so yes it's a great idea to
practice walking around your lab
creating these portraits and certainly
it's an interesting way of getting you
to see but in the end you've got to use
your full-frame digital camera with the
best resolution is an example of where I
had absolutely no time at all to make a
picture for what I knew was going to be
a grand submission so this is a pretty
pretty fast image that I made with my
phone pretty awful part of some
equipment that was necessary in the
research took the image straightened it
out then cropped it like crazy knowing
that eventually the final image was not
going to be up close it was a figure on
the first page of a submission so I did
crop it in doesn't look brilliant right
now but in the next image I edited out
certain pieces and created a laser light
which was all illustrative of course not
for real and so this is what I finally
did I inserted it in a figure that we
used for a page in the submission this
is the page that we finally wound up
with replacing this image the idea
behind this is showing the two next to
each other I hope you agree that the
image that I quickly made on the right
it is more appealing and it is taking up
real estate on the page so why not make
it into a summary graphic as opposed to
putting every single thing you can think
of in a graphic and make it unreadable
this is a way of using very very fast
made images in a submission